yeah hi everyone we are uh going to get
started in just a minute so if you don't
mind taking your seats I'll invite the
panel up to their desks thanks guys
I just want to welcome everybody here in
person at the beautiful Spaceport
Cornwall and online who are joining us
remotely
um it's been a really exciting day and
an exciting couple of weeks for us at
virgin orbit
um so thank you for making the Trek out
here or joining
um virtually we're happy to share this
launch with all of you
um and especially today to talk to you
about what we're looking at
um so just a real quick uh logistical
note like I said we are posting some
people in person as well as online so
we're going to do a little bit of a back
and back and forth flow
where we're going to first answer some
questions in person and then we'll
probably go to the virtual room to make
sure we're giving some time to those
people so
um as we get started
um I just wanted to say we at virgin
orbit as you know we're now in the final
preparation for our next launch it's
called Start Me Up the launch will carry
nine satellites
um for an international pool of space
innovators the U.S national
reconnaissance Office UK defense and
Science and Technology laboratory
satellite applications catapult Horizon
technology the U.S naval research
laboratory Raya group space Forge sat
Revolution and the sultanate of Oman are
all riding aboard our flight this week
so to learn more about each Mission and
customer you can have a look at the
press kit that was sent out to you we're
also delighted to help you connect with
our customers to learn more about their
individual spacecraft so if you have any
specific spacecraft questions
um feel free to connect with one of us
from the media team and we'll put you in
touch with the right people
um a little bit more about the mission
so the launch service was acquired by
the national reconnaissance office the
nro from the Virgin orbit National
assistance subsidiary of Virgin orbit
it's also as you guys know a very
special launch for us because it's the
first International launch for Virgin
orbit it's also the first ever orbital
watch attempt from the United Kingdom or
indeed anywhere else in Western Europe
our panelists today can tell you all
about the incredible collaboration and
effort that made that possible and also
about what it means for Cornwall and for
the UK
a little bit about how the launch
actually works
um before we go into the Q a period so
it uh launcher one is a two-stage rocket
it's mated to a customized upcycled 747
that we call Cosmic girl uh it's going
to depart from a Runway just like any
other normal plane it it'll head out to
its designated drop point and release
the rocket about an hour after that
takeoff
a few seconds after release launcher 1
will ignite its main rocket engine and
begin its moves towards space we'll be
in space for a few minutes later but the
mission will continue until the vehicle
has reached its final orbit and deployed
all of its payloads about an hour or so
after release
as I mentioned previously we're
currently in our final pre-launch
preparations focused on closely
monitoring the health of the system and
our payloads as we get everything ready
for flight our Engineers are pouring
through the data and verifying
everything as we'd like it to be
assuming that everything continues to
look good we're currently tracking well
for launch tomorrow which would should
see a takeoff time somewhere around 9 40
p.m local
um
and uh
until maybe 11 pm local time with the
rocket drop approximately an hour after
that takeoff that said as a standard for
space launch and as you guys have
already learned uh Mission success is
our first priority and if we need to
adjust any part of that schedule we will
we have good Windows later this week and
next week
for following on along with launch we
are live streaming we're also live
tweeting the flight in addition to
hosting many of you here at beautiful
Spaceport portal
so with that
um pleased to introduce our panelists
Ian Annette from the uksa Dan Hart from
Virgin orbit and Melissa Thorpe from
Spaceport Cornwall
um
and with that uh we have about 45
minutes for Q a both virtual and in
person so I am going to start here in
person
um and close my
close my mouth so with that uh
who shall ask the first question
uh just a second someone's gonna bring a
mic to you so we can hear you okay
Victoria Graham from BBC Spotlight
this will be a historic moment for
Cornwall
what relevance will this have to people
sitting at home with a cup of tea just
down the road in their homes
I think what we've seen over the last
eight years is this building of
excitement towards something very
aspirational and different for Cornwall
something that started off as a project
that not a lot of people really believed
it was ever going to happen and we've
just really pushed so hard as a team to
to get to the point that we are today
working with our our friends and family
at virgin net UK space agency and I
think they've seen a small team here in
Cornwall that live and breathe this
County deliver something quite
incredible and so I hope that they're
when they're sitting at home they feel a
bit of inspiration or aspiration and
feel proud of how we're representing
Cornwall going to the Stars I think
there's a lot of Doom and Gloom out
there at the moment and something like
this where you're feeling this
excitement you see all the school
children excited about it you see Nana's
and grandfathers excited about it it
kind of crosses all generations and so I
really think that
um people sitting at home it's just
something exciting it's something
different it's something you don't see
every day somewhere like Cornwall and
it's a bit of an Underdog Story as well
and I think people love an Underdog
Story especially in the UK so I I really
hope that that's what people feel when
they're watching it at home
Thomas must don't use uh Dan can you
explain the concept of a launch window
what governs its start and finish and
what can go wrong at this stage you know
it's blowing a hooley outside but what
conditions can this Cosmic girl actually
take off in sure well I mean a launch
window is the culmination of all of the
inputs that dictate when a rocket can
fly so it has to do with when the
payloads are ready when the rocket and
the rocket system is ready when the
regulatory framework is in place and
where where and the and the coordination
of airspace and and across all the
parties and so that's what really
dictates the launch window
our launch window opens tomorrow night
with a number of opportunities over the
next couple of weeks
we're always geared towards and focused
on the beginning of the window which is
why we're here today
but we will be looking very carefully at
the Readiness of the system as we cross
over right now everything is green the
rocket was armed yesterday
um and where we'll be loading fuel later
today so we're we're in full motion
right now gearing towards the launch
tomorrow that said
um if we see anything interesting that
we want to stop and pause and look at
relative to the system Health if winds
or precipitation or lightning or
something like that is in the area we
will look very closely we're going to
proceed cautiously on this flight we're
in different airspace than we've flown
before our Pilots are ready but we want
to make sure we give them every
opportunity for a successful mission
sure I mean
um you know our the airplane is a very
robust airplane it's 747. uh we do keep
an eye on Crosswinds because we have a
rocket under wing uh and then uh
although we certainly have the ability
to fly above the clouds and we do our
launch above the clouds you know we want
to make sure that things like triggered
lightning or other items uh are not in
the uh a possibility and so we we do
stay very close uh to the med office and
we've gotten some very good uh support
uh from the local Med office here I
highly appreciate that so thanks
foreign
Jordan ride the angry astronaut
um I watched Cosmic girl land in October
I think you guys were hoping to launch
in November and clearly that hasn't
happened
um and I'm curious given the delays
regardless of what may have caused them
has that impacted your future plans of
launching from the United Kingdom
you know we we knew this was not going
to be
um a piece of cake when we took the on
this uh this opportunity we've worked
very closely with the UK space agency
the CAA uh Spaceport Cornwall as well as
um you know the International Community
for airspace I think we've all learned a
lot in doing that
um I I think you know like any first the
first time you do it is difficult the
second time you already know
um you know and can can anticipate and
so the the short answer is we're excited
to be here today we're excited about the
future
um and coming back
maybe as soon as later this year
um
to to to launch again and and hopefully
get a rhythm going we want to be
um a part of the the fabric
of the uh space Community here in the UK
as well as uh globally uh that's our
objective as a company and I think I
think there's a great opportunity
I'd like to add to that as well um and
I'm sure you know Jordan as well when
you look at programs like SLS and NASA
which has had a number of delays of
course until it's got to its first
launch and um and similarly with the
likes of abl who are another partner
that we're working with for Scottish
launches then
um they're waiting for their first
flight as well because because it's it's
difficult right so it's important to
make sure that you get to a safe
successful launch rather than Rush
towards failure and in terms of does it
impact on subsequent launches here from
the UK I would say ABS absolutely not
our role here of course is to create a
commercially sustainable launch
capability but also it's ensuring that
we step through the regulations that
we've we've put in place through primary
legislation there are inevitably things
that we are learning uh from that as
well as we go along and take that at the
right pace in order to make sure that it
can be successful it can build
confidence across the sector and then
people want to come back and launch from
the UK and they see it as a good place
to do business as long as as well as of
course being inspired by the event
itself
the U.S country I just wanted to ask you
know this journey in Cornwall started
all back in 2014 that was when the idea
first came about we're now at the
precipice of the first launch here from
the site how are you feeling right now
like they're butterflies in your
stomachs like kind of what what's the
emotions going through right now
I don't know about you guys I feel
really focused actually I thought I'd
feel nervous or maybe anxious but I
don't I think and that's just because of
the incredible teams that we all have
around us
um there are a lot of them in this room
and across the runway and they have just
absolutely smashed it so that we can go
on and do our jobs and feel really
confident so I feel confident and I feel
focused and I feel ready to to handle
whatever comes our way and I just feel
so excited I feel like seeing yesterday
you know people getting excited in the
public like I cannot wait for for the UK
to to kind of join that exclusive launch
Club because it's it's gonna feel good
you know I just pile on
um you know I always think about my team
they came back just after Christmas
um cutting their holiday shorts so that
we could get through our wet dress
rehearsal uh this past week and so I'm
always thinking about how are they doing
and I'll say the spirits are incredibly
high and I I really attribute that to
you know certainly any space launch is
is exciting and it's exciting to be a
part of but I think the connection to
the community here to the businesses
here and the working relationships and
the mutual excitement about doing a
first launch is really having a mark on
my team and and um you know I'm frankly
very appreciative of the community here
for for giving us that
I think I think I'd say immense
excitement uh who would not be excited
by the fact that this is the first time
that it's been done in Europe uh and and
it's it's because it's hard right and
we've managed to crack all of those
problems but there is a point when the
training takes over and as as Mel said
you kind of fall into that Rhythm of the
teams know what they need to do they
know when they need to make the
decisions they need to make
um and that's good right you want to
make sure that you don't you know you
you don't operate outside that sphere
but it immense excitement for sure and
uh I'd say that the real achievements
here are not the successes that
necessarily you can see it's about all
of the challenges that collectively as a
team people have had to overcome and a
lot of it you don't see whether it's
dealing with International Partners uh
whether it's dealing with different
government departments and bringing them
together in a coherent fashion that that
has really marked an immense amount of
effort and uh and of course the
culmination of all of that is putting
these exciting missions into space as
well it's the things that are at the
pointy end of the rocket that really
matter is all here
I attended parsley from the eye paper
um
how long once it's in the air will you
know the vision's been successful and
um what are you most concerned could go
wrong once it's above the clouds
well let's see the mission
um
we'll we'll take a little bit over an
hour after we leave the airport to get
into position for releasing the rocket
and after that
it's on the order of 50 to 60 minutes
before we have released the satellites
and and gotten the data back on the
orbital uh performance
so it sounds uh it it'll be it'll be
quick
uh you know in as we're watching our
ourselves fly we'll do a three minute
burn on the first stage followed by
about six minutes of second stage burn
will Coast around uh Antarctica uh come
up around uh near Australia and then
we'll watch uh the final burn and the
payloads deployed
um
you know any space flight everything
needs to go right and that's what we're
about
um in terms of the accessibility of the
horizontal launch system how easily can
it be expanded to other airports in the
UK
um are there plans to do this and what
challenges are associated with it
uh that that if they're around uh seven
other space sports that of course been
identified in the UK for both vertical
and horizontal launch
um the likes of for example snowdonia as
well and uh Glasgow presswick or other
horizontal launch sites and they're very
much in the stages of development of
course and uh either with their own
Regional uh governments or indeed as
private entities so the the
opportunities
um are there of course you've got to see
to ensure that there's a market there
that can uh that can support that and
but what I would say of course there is
always if you're first to Market uh if
you're there first doing it then you
almost create an anchor type uh uh
opportunity as well so you know the
Spaceport here it's got its license
it'll demonstrate that it's been
operating as a Spaceport as well so
that's a that's a that's a real gem that
uh that corn will have got of course
hi Vicky from The Daily Mail I just
wanted to ask if you see space tourism
operating out of Cornwall at any point I
also wondered if there's anything
personal on board that anybody's taking
anything Cornish 10 pasties I don't know
um yeah so we've we we're pretty much
focused 100 on satellite launch at the
moment that's challenging as it is
um before we you add humans to that mix
um but you know the the future of of
more crude space flight in the future is
is changing the Technologies are
changing we've announced an mou a Sierra
space for instance which is as a return
Landing site which may have people on
board that in the future as well the
Cornwall Council has always said we'll
we'll have to have another look at it if
we do start to look at space space human
space flight as a Spaceport we're really
interested in human space flight and the
opportunities with you know researchers
going up for microgravity experiments
for instance
um but also of course yeah there's
there's a lot going on in in the tourism
side of it as well and putting some of
these um into more humans into space to
see the curvature of the earth and when
they come back down and and do when they
when they get back after that being
influenced by that overview effect so I
think we'll start to look up you know
the the opportunities in that but 100
focus on satellite launch at the moment
I I'd add to that as well if certainly
focusing on the human space flight
element of it rather than space tourism
um of course there's no policy
requirement for Space tourism
um within the within the UK at the
moment but of course from a human space
flight perspective we'll have to see
what the uh what the future holds in
terms of personalization
um then I I would just add of course one
of the important parts about uh this
program is the inspiration that it
provides and as part of that we've had a
number of competitions that have been
run one of which was for youngsters to
have a liftoff logo competition uh which
a young chap from Preston won and you
know the the prize for winning that was
to have his logo inside the fairing uh
of this launch as well so uh young
Callum from Preston age six I'm sure
we'll be very excited to see his logo
that represents the values of this
Mission actually going up into uh into
space and that's just an example of how
we should be thinking about inspiring
that younger generation to get into this
this sector
and if I could pile on a little bit to
that you know through covid we were
working together
and virtually I think we've had about 10
000 students in our Factory uh with our
Engineers talking about space and
Rockets and and how they fly
um and so we've actually touched quite a
bit of the community already
um and I do want to bring us back to the
inspiring satellites because that's what
this mission is all about
um you know Manufacturing in space
uh different ways of using GPS and and
navigation
different Technologies for satellites
understanding Maritime
behaviors and and illegal fishing and
and
um piracy and things like that I I think
in the world that we're in
um as well as the important Allied
collaboration from the National Security
Community
um I think we can all personally connect
with one or more of the satellites that
are flying on this mission
really I have feelings Gap filled with
the Felix's space-time educational
YouTube channel what
um what educational opportunities will
space support Cornwall
present to young people who have an
interest in Aerospace in the short term
and the long term
Hi Felix thanks for that
um well you're here and that's fantastic
this is what it's all about and I've
said this many times the reason my whole
team get up every single morning is to
inspire the Next Generation
Um that's that's what we all should be
trying to do to get not just into the
space industry but stem in general and
launch inspires it's actually really
easy to go into a school and get kids
excited about space launch the hard bit
is then showing them the pathways into
the industry so my team have been
working incredibly hard on developing
Partnerships with local colleges and
universities we've actually set up
institutes and built facilities already
so that people go for intro can can
become you know start to work on
satellites in college working with
University of Exeter we've written
modules on things like space economics
so starting to think outside the box
it's not just about the aerospace
engineering side of it anymore you can
bring in like insurance and law and the
humanities
um and so for for us it's just important
that we kind of show the breadth of the
industry and all the different things
that could be possible including the
Arts as well so just trying to break
down some of those perceptions of the
space industry something we're proud of
and but really the big thing is is
getting people up on site and showing
them and we've done a lot of that that
massive rocket behind you there
um that is the replica rocket that was
built by the UK space agency we've had
thousands of kids already come up and
see that and be talked through that so
having something physical really helps
and I think after the launch we have a
lot of plans to take tours through the
integration facility and just get kids
living and breathing what's on their
doorstep for the first time so lots
planned we've been working with Disney
for instance we've got a young space
crew that will be following along the
launch tomorrow so there's just so many
it's it's kind of endless but it's the
best bit of the job definitely
foreign
I'm on a mission to inspire a million
kids to wait higher than my hive is
you are very inspiring people you're
obviously very successful you're up
there and I'm down here
um I wonder if you could all think back
to when you were young that moment that
spark you had that teacher that place
that thing you did that brought you here
today that inspired your journey because
I think that's what we've got to find
and encourage our young people to find
well let's see I mean my spark I guess
was the summer of 1969.
um and my parents made me stay up late I
was in New York
and watch a grainy picture of uh two men
come off of a
a Contraption onto the lunar surface
and it made me realize that what they
possibilities are
that there was a tremendous amount of
Hope and goodness in
in being able to operate in moving
humankind into space
and um
you know that just has has carried uh me
into a community uh of
an incredible community of innovation
and and uh terrific people who are all
striving for the same ideals and and
that's a very powerful force and I would
say that for the community here
um having spent time in Cape Canaveral
and and other launch sites there's
something about knowing that somebody
down the block
is working on a space flight mission
that sort of breaks the barrier down and
makes it go from being something that's
very far away to being something that is
around the corner and something that a
child would say you know I could do that
I I never did I ever think that I would
be uh sat on this stage or indeed you
know running this program as the senior
responsible owner I'd kind of go back to
I do remember even though I've got more
gray hair than Dan I certainly remember
1969 as a very very young baby but I
think if I go back to August and
September 1977 uh was when Elvis died
but at the same time Voyager 1 Voyager 2
were being launched and they're still
continuing out on their Journey beyond
the earth sphere which is the final kind
of constraints of the Galaxy and I
remember that very much as a child and
giving me that spark about wanting to be
uh involved with physics and engineering
and that I think is probably where the
journey has started I mean I've never
been one for for planning uh where I'll
be next but that I think was very much
the start for me and I've been very
lucky and I've worked very hard to
improve my engineering skills
um and I think that was very much the
start of the journey I'd probably take
it back to August and September 1977 and
the start of Voyager one and two
I think for me it's slightly different
um I grew up in a very very remote part
of British Columbia Canada and for me I
think the spark was the night sky
um was um
I was so fortunate enough to grow up
with the Northern Lights quite
frequently in the winter and so for me I
guess it was more a spark of wonder what
is out there what what are humans going
to do out there what are we going to see
out there what are we going to find out
there
um and I unfortunately had a teacher
that told me when I said I'd be I was
interested in astronomy that there was
no future in that where I was so think
about doing something else
um so ha here I am
um but it took me a little bit longer
than uh it probably should have and I
think that's kind of set the tone for my
mission is to never let a teacher say
that to children to show that absolutely
you can do something like this on your
doorstep especially girls I have two
daughters myself and I see you know how
they're treated sometimes very
differently and that's not okay so for
me it's really important that um you
know as the head of the Spaceport that
I'm in schools and I'm talking to girls
and working with programs like Tech
girls to get girls excited about Steam
and excited about entering the industry
of space as well so it's been a bit of a
journey for me I never expected like Ian
to be set you know doing this but um I
just I'm so immensely proud of of what I
have achieved thanks
hi Kate Duffy from Business Insider
um obviously this is such a significant
launch where does this launch put the UK
in the space industry where does it
place it
so
um
if you look at
I mean we've we you know the space
injuries worth around about 60 and a
half billion pounds annually to the UK
economy and employs 47 000 people and
that's growing and uh we are absolutely
fantastic at designing satellites and
building satellites you know I always
use the heuristic that we build more
satellites here in the UK than anywhere
outside of the US
and we're also great at operating
satellites as well as exploiting the
data which is a really really important
end of it as well so we're kind of on a
journey and this helps us with that
journey and fills that what I call that
end-to-end capability so you can do
everything with
we are the fourth largest spender in the
European space agency and we've
increased our commitment to over 1.85
billion pounds to uh to the European
space agency and uh and we work very
closely of course with our European
space agency and also bilaterally with
other countries and uh such
organizations as NASA so the so the UK
is is kind of as respected as a
um uh as a as you know as a proven space
nation and if you look at some of those
missions that have been launched
recently whether it be the Mars
perseverance which had UK technology on
it or whether you look at
um
uh uh the James Webb Space Telescope
who's medium for a red instrument was
actually pressed by the UK and as the
principal investigator for that was from
the UK so the UK is very respected in
space and this again continues to
reinforce that and allows us to grow so
we can achieve being that science
superpower as well as contributing
towards the economy and inspiring the
next generation of people who will come
ultimately to take over from the likes
of us
okay um we're going to pause in-person
questions for a second so we can take a
few from uh our online joiners
um so I'm going to start off
um
thinking back to where we are right now
at Spaceport Cornwall
um at airport leuki
um what are the main challenges of
turning an airport into a Spaceport is
is the first part of that question and
then
um
maybe for uh Dan specifically does
virgin orbit have other launch locations
in site elsewhere in the world
um and what are the lessons learned from
this experience of turning Spaceport
Cornwall into the first UK Spaceport you
want to stir it yeah I think initially
it was probably just belief that we
could
um we were actually quite confident as a
team that we had what we take this
amazing asset that we have here at
Cornwall airport Niki one of the longest
runways in the UK and access over the
sea and also just the will of of the
team here at the airport to think oh
wait wait a minute we can turn into a
Spaceport so I believe I would say it
was the start but the the foundations
that are already here meant that we
could have probably oh don't miss NCAA
but we could have launched the day after
we were potentially announced from a
facilities perspective you know we have
this fantastic Runway and that could
handle 747s and we've done so
um so turning this Spaceport into the
airport into the Spaceport has has
really just been to Future proof it a
lot of it and to grasp the opportunity
from The Wider space industry so we've
done things to the site like strengthen
taxiways and turn pads at the end of the
runway so that Cosmic girl can maneuver
a lot easier and more efficiently and
we've done things like build our Space
Systems integration facility where the
satellites are integrated into the
fairing of the rocket we never plan to
build that building initially but we had
an opportunity to to get a little bit of
funding and and that's really exciting
for us because of course it's being used
by virgin it's a fantastic world-class
facility but when Virgin are not here we
can open it up to other companies we
have a brand new facility that's that's
opening adjacent to that which will have
other space companies it's full and we
haven't even opened it yet that's how
excited people are so we're just
building on what's already here that the
airport has and we've we've added a few
bits and pieces that will future proof
the site and make it a little bit
bespoke to some parts of what virgin
required as well but you know to be able
to develop an airport for less than 20
million pounds to turn into a space
board I think is pretty pretty amazing
actually yeah I would say you know
number one the G7 was a great Proving
Ground for for bringing in 747s
um so that was convenient uh you know
Spaceport Cornwall has been a phenomenal
host first of all
so thank you thanks for being here you
know as far as the the complexities look
dealing with Logistics dealing with
planning coordinating timelines
um and and setting up you know when
we're doing uh uh operations with
hazardous materials and making sure we
have the right coordination the right
regulatory uh approvals those are the
complexities those are the hard Parts
um the good thing uh looking ahead is we
now have learned all those
um and and going ahead we we've got them
you know there's other things like like
coordinating our our fly outs and
airspace and things like that which is
kind of similar those are where the
complexities are overall the coming here
and turning a slab of some men into a
Spaceport uh went incredibly smoothly
um I think I think within a handful of
days we were up and operating from blank
cement to launch operations center and
so uh you know it's been an incredible
journey uh and you know now we're here
and then following up on
that Dan could you talk a little bit
more about the different launch
locations inside elsewhere around the
world and what's next sure I mean we've
been having discussions across the globe
I mean the ability to come to an airport
and turn a slab of cement into a
Spaceport is something that's very
interesting and and generally has has
never really been done before
um and so there's a quite a bit of
Interest we have agreements that we have
uh announced recently with in Australia
in Japan
um we we have a an agreement with
Luxembourg looking across NATO needs
um and so you know we see a great
opportunity to provide
really change the framework for launch
you know launch was traditionally done
in a couple places in the world
um and and regions and countries you
know couldn't do it
well with our technology and the will
and the Technologies within
um the UK and other countries where now
satellite companies are all over the
place
um it'll be natural to have an ecosystem
where there's launch and spacecraft
manufacturing and operations and I think
that's the model of the future and we're
going to see that you know each region
will want a piece of that of that future
um
so we are going from this is from
Aerospace we are going from the UK
having no
um Sovereign space access to seven
spaceports and launchers coming online
um the question I believe this is for
Ian is without a strong anchor tenant
like
can the UK support all these heating
space courts and what are your outlooks
for that
I'd I'd say to that that uh the space
economy is not static particularly in
low earth orbits if you look at the
number of small satellites that were
launched back in 2012 I think it was
something like 500 or so if you look at
the number of launches that took place
last year or 2021 uh there was two 1 900
1 700 of those were small satellites so
the market is changing rapidly there is
a strong demand for micro launchers and
to get some more satellites into uh into
low earth orbit so there's more than
enough in terms of a demand signal for
us to uh to respond to so certainly we
don't need to rely on those large
National academies such as such as NASA
and I think that the UK can certainly
demonstrate that it can compete in the
small satellite launch market for the
foreseeable future and in terms of the
number of spaceports that we've got as
well then again I think there's an
opportunity for them to develop and
demonstrate that if they're competitive
for launch then again they can get after
what we call that addressable
addressable Market as well but I would
say that having both horizontal and
vertical launch capabilities are very
much complementary as well so I don't
see them as a competitive capability I
see them as offering different uh
capabilities and therefore there's
certainly room for vertical and
horizontal launch here in the UK in a
global market that continues to grow
Melissa can you give us an update on
chronosat and when you expect to launch
and what the latest is for that
our lockdown baby colonosa so kernosa is
our community satellite that we
we kind of came together to think about
how can we engage the local community
with space how can we bring space down
to earth and down to an area like
Cornwall and we thought what if we came
up with a small satellite that could
help benefit a local issue and so
Colonel sat 1 was born out of that and
at G7 we were the Prime Minister Boris
Johnson at the time announced funding
for it and we are designing and building
and launching and tracking colonel from
Cornwall for Cornwall so it is a small
communication satellite that will work
with sensors around the coast of
Cornwall and it will monitor our ocean
Health around the coast of Cornwall and
it will do things like one of the
projects we're working with is looking
at seagrass restoration off the coastal
Cornwall we're looking at
monitoring the temperature visibility
pollution levels our end goal is really
to plant a kelp farm for carbon
sequestration in the future and you use
it as a great case study and how we can
use blue carbon to help with some of the
local environmental issues here as well
as engaged local schools so the schools
will be helping us and we've run a few
think tanks already that John pavith has
run with local universities getting the
students involved and not just the
design of of the satellite but also
looking at how we process the data
getting the kids to help us with that as
well so Kronos at one is in the process
of being built and we're hoping to
launch it potentially on the second
launch if not the third
with Virgin and very much it's just the
start of a program of future satellites
that we just want to get bigger and
better we've been blown away by how much
interest there is in this a project like
this it sounds simple like you know to
create a tech piece of technology for
the community but to what we've seen is
the excitement around okay we can really
bring space right down to Earth by by a
project like this so something we're
really
awesome I have one more question from
online and then I'll take a couple more
questions in the room uh people are
eager to have a few more questions in
um I think this one is is probably best
suited for Dan but others can jump in
why is the launch happening at night
well you know spacecraft have uh their
requirements and each one has a mission
um one of our spacecraft has a
requirement associated with where they
are at a specific point of the day and
when it crosses the equator is how it's
defined and so that defines
the launch time you know again the
purpose of the launch
is to make sure that the satellites on
board
um you know have the right orbits and
and have the right ability to conduct
their missions and that's why we're
doing it late at night
great is there anyone else in person
we'll get you a mic just a second
uh Nathan Hunkin from chaos TV and radio
um it's been quite an exciting journey
to get to where we are today and I know
everyone wishes you did the best of luck
for tomorrow with that in mind what is
the message to the International Space
Community
um here forward from little old new key
here in Cornwall and and if I may with
sustainability and reusability in mind
can you tell us a little bit about why
virgin obvious is such a great valuable
option
wow what's the message you know I would
say number one you know space has become
such an incredible part of our life
um from the way we communicate to the
way we navigate to how we understand our
world and the heavens Beyond
um but space is now coming to you is the
message you know our one of the purposes
in virgin orbit is to open up space for
everyone
and that's exactly what we're doing
um in that space is not a far away thing
that somebody else does anymore it's
what communities across the world do and
and you know that's a large part of what
our organization is about
I think just to add to that we're really
proud of working with Virgin Orbit on
our sustainability
um because where I think the first kind
of partnership that's actually looked at
things like our carbon impact so being
transparent about what our impact is in
the first place as Dan said satellites
are so fundamental in everyday life now
but the way they get to space currently
is impacting the environment which tends
to seem quite ironic to a lot of people
and I understand that so we want to do a
better job but actually how we can get
this incredible technology to space but
in a more responsible way in a more
sustainable way in a more ethical way it
end in a more transparent way and that's
why you can find out about exactly what
our impact is that's been helped by the
regulations that the UK have put in
place and that we're not just going to
stop there we want to look at how we can
work with Virgin orbit and other
operators to bring that impact down work
towards carbon neutrality in the first
instance and bring in things like
nature-based solutions to the site even
how we're working with projects like the
Eden project and bring people back know
a lot more about sustainability than
than I do to to kind of be our critical
friends and help us on this journey
because I truly as an environmentalist
myself believe in the power and space to
make earth a better place but we just
need to be aware of of the impact that
we do have in getting the tech to space
and how we can do it better yeah just
maybe jumping on that a little further I
mean you know we have a unique method of
flying to space and a real reuse in that
if you think back on all the launches
that you've seen usually you're watching
the wildlife in a wildlife preserve and
then a very Fierce powerful rocket lifts
off and flies to space we're going to
take we're going to reuse a 747 uh
tomorrow a Runway
we'll leave the ground
um in a normal way that we all fly uh go
out
up to 35
000 feet and the rocket will start there
a more efficient approach and a much
lighter touch approach than normal so
there's an environmentally we we sort of
have taken a big leap with this
technology and then of course everything
that Mel just said about you know we
understand what's going on in our planet
we understand how to optimize our
behaviors
um largely because of what we understand
from space I'd say that a Boeing 747 is
probably the ultimate reusable first
stage
um you know I think Falcon 9 are
probably up to around about 90 times
before they start to think about whether
they should replace it so I wouldn't
like to think about the cycle time on
Cosmo girl it's probably been up and
down quite a few more times than uh than
that and in terms of sustainability then
the UK is of course it's a principal
driver for the United Nations long-term
sustainability uh goals as well so we're
very very much attuned to that
particularly through our regulatory
environment so for before you can
license any uh satellite on Space you
have to make sure that they can
demonstrate they need those
sustainability values and that's
sustaining space as a domain as well as
actually looking at what it does on
Earth as well so we can protect that
fragile environment as much as the one
that we have within the atmosphere as
well
hi uh Alex Wilkins from New Scientist
um the past four launches have all been
in California and now we're in UK near
the coast what are the biggest changes
you've had to make launching in UK and
have you faced any massive challenges
from launching in such a different
environment now
I would say uh pasties versus hamburgers
uh you know it was a significant shift
um you know from the from the operation
of the system it's essentially the same
matter of fact we did we did a launch
rehearsal in California before we came
uh here just to make sure we checked
everything before we left the U.S
certainly the the Partnerships are
probably the biggest differences you
know
um and I and I I really
we're very appreciative of the
Partnerships that have been in place as
we mentioned I mean the airport
Logistics the UK space agency Spaceport
Cornwall the RAF
um you know the CAA and and all of the
other organizations
um though that's probably the biggest
difference but in terms of the
technology and how we operate a little
different weather than Mojave
um but otherwise the the team is turning
the wrenches in the same way
I think Stanley's been surprised at how
many people are going to be showing up
tomorrow to watch it because he said in
Mojave like two people maybe look
through the fence because they see it so
much over there
little bit different
I Ollie from Cornwall live I just wanted
to ask you you mentioned more launches
in the future if if this one works very
well
um have you got time scale have you got
a plan for two or three months two or
three a year what's the what's the
future looking like for Cornwall here
we you know we would we would like to be
back
um if we could before the end of the
year I'm not sure that will happen but
it's not out of the question
um you know certainly our Focus right
now is is today and tomorrow
um but we're in discussions right now
there's work to do across the payload
Community again it starts with a payload
um but there are a number of ideas
percolating working with UK space agency
and the rest of the community so you
know we would like to start a rhythm I
think right now we're very very focused
clearly on on launch number one
I think it's it's very clear to me that
that virgin orbit have made a strong
commitment to being a global operator
you need bought two new aircraft two
aircraft again to supplement their
existing operations in order to do that
globally and the UK very much wants to
be part of that and I think that we can
demonstrate that we will be you know
Europe's principal
um launch operator particularly having
done it for the first time and then
complementing that against other sites
that we've got so very much you know
this is not a One-Shot
um and then and then go away again you
know we need to make sure that we can
work together and demonstrate that you
can launch the right missions and be
competitive and it's it's not just
competitive on price it's having the
right legal framework regulatory
framework
um operating in a stable democracy helps
as well so there's many many factors
here that will make the UK an attractive
place for people to operate from I think
it's worth noting as well as
um very much virgin orbit as our
pretended but we have other operators
that will be coming to use the site when
Virgin are not here and as as I
mentioned before we're really developing
the kind of cluster around it virgin
orbit are quite a magnet of interest for
other space companies to co-locate and
to be alongside and that's why I meant
we we filled a building already with
other companies looking to to move to
the site so very much when when VR are
launching elsewhere in the world will be
very active on site here and the beauty
of the airport is it's not all eggs in
one basket it's not just launch at this
site there's so many other things going
on at the airport that were just one
kind of business activity here so it
means that we can develop lots of
different parts of the business and that
makes it a lot more sustainable as a
Spaceport we're not just holy you know
waiting for Virgin to to come and launch
every year we have lots of other
activities going on
Christopher virgin orbits I'm at the
beginning of 2022 there was news that
you guys first of all were planning on
reusing the first stage of launcher one
as well as we're using the 747 and also
to add a third stage possibly powered by
ion engines uh can you comment about any
of those new technologies sure I mean we
have a we've got a wonderful product but
there's a when whenever you have a
technology you are evolving it and so
you know there there's a lot of
opportunity to flex and uh the
performance of our system both in terms
of more payload to orbit as well as
reaching orbits
um like lunar or interplanetary and so
we do have a partnership with exoterra
that we announced last year that we're
developing a electric Upper stage
in support of some NASA activity and
some other International
activity that we have
um
let's see I didn't the rest of your
question
um
oh reusability and and we continue to
look at reusability you know we have a
very simple first stage
so the economics is not completely clear
it closes when you get through the full
logistic uh life cycle there it's not
out of the cards we haven't yet
committed to reuse but it is something
in our trade space that we continue to
um evaluate and we've got concept
Concepts that are that are in
development
foreign
hours away from the launch can you kind
of paint a picture for people at home
about what the atmosphere is going to be
like in the control room
sure I think Mel said it right focused
um you know you you have a bubbling of
excitement within
um but you have to sort of put that
aside and the team right now is smiling
but uh you know their eyes are laser
sharp as we were going through our
checkouts and going through our
Communications
you know space launch is a very serious
business we'll and we'll be looking at
integrating all the information about
the system about the weather about the
range and anticipating and supporting
each other as we go through a very
exciting but very rigorous process
I have one more online question I think
we're going to take one more in person
after that um so
um this is I think for the group in
different ways how much interest have
you had from the UK Ministry of defense
or other countries outside of the U.S
for security related responsive launch
using the launcher one system
well first of all you know we are
honored
to have on board the national response
office
dstl the naval research lab
you know the whole idea of of working on
a mission where the mod and RAF and
space force and the nro are
collaborating where we can facilitate
Allied collaboration is it's an honor
and it's so important today
certainly Ukraine woke up the world in a
lot of ways and were in a different
place than we used to be I don't know if
everybody's noticed it but over the last
year we've all gotten used to
understanding what's going on by seeing
overhead images
something that the National Security
Community has done for decades we now do
with our families every night and over
while we're watching the news so that's
a huge change
um so you know clearly
there is a whole a pan-european
um as well as a U.S collaboration and
desire to collaborate across allies to
make sure that that space capability is
always there for us and that we have
responsiveness
so that if something happens in the
world we can get assets there right away
and we happen to have a space launch
system that operates like an airplane
because it has an airplane and that's
something that has been thought about
for decades
and is now here and so you know we're
excited to be a
supporting incredible innovation in the
commercial world
and and you know space Forge and uh and
catapult and all the other uh sat rev
and all the other uh commercial uh
programs uh where and we're equally
excited to be here at the heart of
Allied collaboration in space
I'd add to that Dan that I mean I've
been involved in this game for a number
of years where I've seen a transition
that goes from space being the
preeminent use of National Security
military activities and that's kind of
transitioned now to very much a
commercial opportunity so it's
inevitable that of course those
commercial capabilities uh can either
have dual purpose or it's indeed a
shared shared expense so I find myself
working much closer with the UK's
Ministry of defense and indeed other
allies as well from a civil perspective
because it's that natural transition
whether it's because it gives you
greater resilience or redundancy or
duality of systems whether that's for
position navigation and timing or
Communications or Earth observation or
it gives you quicker access for things
like Earth observation as we've seen in
uh in Ukraine as well so it's a it's a
natural transition that both helps us
develop security capabilities but also
actually for governments it keeps costs
down whilst also providing commercial
opportunities as well
great and with that I think we're going
to close out our time today thank you
again everyone for joining us in person
and online
um we'll still be available for a few
minutes here in Newquay to answer
questions
um
um but we look forward to seeing you
tomorrow for the launch have a great
afternoon
thank you
thank you